nice to see you it's been a few
a little while since sundance yes yes
um so i have a million questions and i
have six minutes so let's just get
started
um do you think do you think the movie
if it not been for covet obviously there
you never know if this movie would even
exist but if you had the opportunity
to film on location do you think you
would have done anything like
adding a location to this film or did
you always envision it
um as one location um look i think the
the the restrictions that kovid uh
required was um
uh is what made this film
possible so just in the sense that you
know
i wanted it to be a sort of we needed it
to be as safe as possible so as bare
bones as possible two actors one house
one location
essentially one long scene no real
special effects props
location moves no bells and whistles
um one camera a few lights
that's it um not extensive you know art
direction
so you know that's kind of what was
exciting about it is
how how can i you know it was sort of
born out of this exercise of can we
tell us a story that's engaging
and uh emotional and moving and
cinematic
but with you know the very few resources
you did the roger deakins of just one
camera one one shot no coverage
yeah we tend to i mean i tend to shoot
euphoria that way too i mean i would say
80
some odd percent of euphoria is just
single camera um
as well but uh yeah i just i prefer one
camera only because
then you're not having to compromise
lighting wise and
and movement wise so uh how many days
did you actually
allow yourself to shoot this movie uh
we shot for 14 days but uh
funnily enough the first day of shooting
i kind of had the uh marcel rev and i
cinematographer who i always collaborate
with um we had a
very kind of you know uh you know uh
sort of formalist idea of how we're
gonna shoot it is gonna be like a
premanger film
all dolly work very old school so
where should we shoot the first day
we're looking at it we get into the car
i say great work the actors we shoot
about you know 15 pages get into the car
i said this isn't this looks like a
whiskey commercial we gotta scrap it i
can't you know and he's like i
completely agree
it's not messy enough we need more life
in it we go to sleep we wake up the next
morning we go to set
and we we decided we're gonna shoot the
whole thing handheld it's gonna be like
bullet ballet or something you know like
messy handheld black and white tell the
actors great we shoot all day i look
up marcel he's got a thousand foot mag
on his shoulder he's like covered in
sweat and i just kind of shake my head
and he shakes his head
and we know in that instant that we're
literally gonna throw that day out too
the only problem is i don't want to tell
the actors because i don't want them to
be like are you kidding we just didn't
done 80 takes of the first 15 minutes
and we're gonna throw it out so i'm like
great work let's go to sleep
come back tomorrow and only on the third
day when we were setting out for that
exterior shot did i think we did the
whole film click and that's when we
realized
okay this is the movie we need to start
objectively
we need to look at it as a play in some
senses because
the structure of it is very specific
there is no act breaks there's no
place that it's it's heading it's just a
sort of socratic
dialogue uh you know where these two
characters are just
taking shots at one another and that's
when we discovered
kind of how we were gonna shoot it and
then we needed a couple extra days and
that's what got us to 14 days total
including first of all it's an amazing
story that i wish i could dig deep on
but i don't have time did you guys ever
consider
at all going to a studio and saying
would you like to pay for this would you
like to finance
because i believe you you guys did it on
your own
yeah no we never we we never wanted to
do that only because we wanted to
first of all we wanted to create a
financial structure um for the movie
that um
uh where we could uh where we could give
our crew
actual back end in the in the film so
that in
in in success they were able to kind of
you know share
in the benefits and also we wanted to
carve out a portion of the back end for
feeding america and donate it um uh to
charity so we wanted full control over
in that sense and also we didn't want to
have to answer to anybody
so like as i was writing you know my
producer kevin turner called me he was
like sam you better finish this script
because i just put 80 000
worth of black and white film on my
credit card and
my wife is saying i just booked some
hotels z's putting in money and it's
just
we just kept it going that way um and uh
because i don't think we would have been
able to we wouldn't have been able to
to to come up with this structure which
i think is
a structure that's important in terms of
filmmaking i have never understood why
julio perez the editor that i work with
marcel rep
i don't understand why they don't have
ownership
in in the films that we make together
they are as
important as any other person on that
set
and we wanted to reflect that um
and and have uh uh something to point to
in the future
i gotta stop i'm just gonna say congrats
on the movie next time we'll do a longer
conversation please
i would love that thank you